hey guys this is andrew from
chickensenses.com so i've been working
as a professional trader
on the option market for the past six
years in hong kong and i've just created
my youtube channel where i share with
you all the knowledge i have
about how to make money on the market so
in today's video i want to show you guys
how to use options
to build some strategies that
can help you to actually make big big
big profits
without sometimes taking a lot of risk
so let's get into it
[Music]
all right guys so once again i'm gonna
show you
something that you guys gonna love i'm
sure of that
so this is actually i don't want to go
too deep into that i know this is very
you know complicated stuff
okay so i showed you guys already i'm
using like the option data to compute
the synthetic short interest
but in today's video i want to show you
something
much more interesting i want to once
again
slowly show you the more technical
things we can do in finance as traders
especially on the option market and i
want to show you some very basic
option strategies that you can use to
make money on those markets so
for example let's start very basically
for example you have no shares so
okay your share position is zero
you don't have any option for now so
you don't make any money and you want to
buy for example
300 cold strike so if you buy one of the
quantity
it means you buy like 100 options so to
find the price of your options
so we're gonna stay today on the july
maturity you go on yahoo finance you
click on options
you select your maturities so let's stay
on the july maturity because it's
kind of easier to start and you want to
buy a 300 call
strike so let's see the price you need
to take into account
count is the uh so here i have bid and
ask last price is only the last traded
price
but it doesn't mean it's what it's worth
on the close
all right because maybe it has not
traded around the close so
don't pay attention to last price or
just do the average between bid and ask
so here the average between bid and ask
is 19
19.4 exactly so
your price is 19.4
and the volatility it's interesting for
you just to
you know put it i'm gonna explain after
what's the effect of it but just okay
put it and then
i compute my premium so the premium is
only equal
to the number of options so here 100
because one option on the listed market
is multiplier of 100
so it's equivalent to 200 and options uh
contract
and the price is 19.4 so this would be a
premium of
1900 usd
and how would this look so
i'm having here my 300 call
and so basically it's a payoff that is
giving you all the upside performance
above the strike level so basically if
we finish
at 300 your call option at maturity your
call option is worth
nothing so if you finish at 325
you have gained 25 per
option and you have 100 of them so it's
200
and uh 2 000 5 000 so you basically are
break even around the strike because
your total p
l is the performance of your call option
minus the price of your call options
so your payoff is something like this
all right so this is if you buy a call
option
300 strike so you know but you have no
downside risk so this
is the good thing about it for example
imagine you don't have this
and you have for example here it was
equivalent to 100 let's say you have 20
shares
your p l is very different so for for
now we had 160
so if we finish here in july you only
gonna use 200
us dollar but if we finish at zero you
can lose a maximum
of three thousand two hundred us dollar
but you know on the upside
you you cannot make uh as much as you
could
if you have like uh so the risk is
roughly the same
you know you can use even twice more but
for that gamestop needs to go to zero
and the upside performance
is linear for call option you have some
convexity i mean
you don't have convexity above the
strike but you have convexity at spots
so let's go back to this
and now i want to show you something
more interesting that you can do
is actually if you don't don't spend
that much money
you can just decide to buy
a call at 300 because you think that
gamestop is going to be above 300 but
you think gets
gamestop is not going to make new
all-time high so i think gamestop is
going to be lower
than 480 so let's call it 475
so you buy one here and you sell one
here
so what's the price you're gonna sell it
475 between eight
and uh fourteen so it's around eleven
eleven and ten so 11.10
what's the volatility 180 all right
slightly higher which is good you want
to sell those higher volts
so basically this is okay and now
interesting because it's not that
expensive anymore
it's it doesn't cost 1900 it costs only
800 us dollars
and the performance between 300 and 475
is exactly the same all right
we have just capped the maximum gains to
16 000
us dollars so let me show you again how
we were
if you don't sell it you are like this
so if we go to
475 we are making
the same sixteen thousand us dollars and
of course we can make more if we go
above but
discuss two thousand us dollars and if
we
sell the upside call together
we make the same money here guys all
right we just
you just don't have the upside
performance above your second
strike so this is another option
strategy that you can make which is
called a call spread and i think that
code spreads actually
very good to sell when the
upside volatility is that high guys all
right look at this volatility this
column
and it's that high because everybody is
actually buying loot guys the open
interest on the 800 strike is 22
000 so we are talking here about two
million equivalent shares
and you can see that you know which is
amazing and that's why
you know this is pushing that a lot of
buyers here
so when they buy uh the call option
actually by its volatility
i'm gonna explain guys this in other
videos for now i want to keep it simple
just keep in mind that they are pushing
the those prices higher
so you guys want to be on the right side
the right side is not to buy those
strikes right is to sell it i'm telling
you guys so this is my job
and you know i think it's good i'm
telling you
that you need to sell those very high
strikes
so you can sell them as i said by
buying a one that is lower and if you
want you can even sell
two you know and this
would make it look like this and then it
costs to zero this is a cool
ratio so once again i go step by step
guys but this is a one by two
uh july 300 475
uh gamestop call ratio this is how we
would call it at work
and this costs zero and your payoff
has you know a shape that basically
you're making the maximum money
at 475 you're making now 18 000 u.s
dollars
but you start to lose money if we go
above 6 50 in
july which is possible so you need to be
careful
and let me show you something you can
also
add some shares you can add for example
if you have 20 shares you
have your 20 shares and then your payoff
is like this
so basically you can do whatever you
want with options
so that's it for me i want to keep it
simple in this video i'm going to do
more videos where i show you
more options strategies that you can use
especially
if you are long and you're gonna see
guys that this is very
very helpful to actually lock some
profits
and it's even very good to use instead
of buying the deep you can sell some put
options this is my next video so if you
enjoyed this one please don't forget to
click on the sub
like and bell button so you're going to
be the first to know when i upload
anything new
and stay close to show see you guys